what are your hopes for 2021 then after
i mean
i think we all had hopes for 2020 that
went down the yeah do you not feel that
like
surviving a year on youtube is a success
almost like every year you you still
no i don't do it you're like like i
can't i come into every year thinking
this is my last year
and i've said this this is where it ends
i said that i've said that for about 10
years now and i'm like i think so if you
get too comfortable
this platform has a way of sweeping as a
youtuber you just see
people who just fall off the face of the
planet in the
span of like a month yeah right it's
scary
um like so many channels disappear as
quickly as they come and they
are quickly replaced with new and
upcoming challenges
what defines what what leads to a
channel what leads to a channel to sort
of disappear do you think or
lose i i think as as connor said like
most of the time it's comfort i think
it's yeah complications
over comfort just being like you know i
have all these subscribers i you know a
lot i
don't of course i don't want to say any
names
but you know there's a lot of channels
that are you know much more on the
higher subscriber range who
kind of are just like i can make
anything at this point and i'll probably
still get views
i think you're in a good spot where
you're you kind of have to keep going to
new things with your content
the way you've built it has forced you
to do that but you know uh for a channel
like my own
i could do i have reoccurring series and
i could just pump the same ones out
yeah like the videos that tend to do the
best on above japan i'm usually just
near my room
right at the comments right yeah yeah
yeah but i feel maybe it's because you
do that
now so like very often compared to what
but like you have to on youtube right
because you can't constantly be going
and doing these like week long but
that's what i'm saying like if chris did
videos where
you know you were just in your room
reading hate comments or going through
your spam or like you know just
commentating
verbally rather than showing it then i
feel people would start to be like oh
this is kind of repetitive
yeah but i think it's the fact that you
just every so now and then throw it in
i think i just try and mix everything up
with the contour like one week i've got
like a bullet train next week i've got
hate mail the week after
right and that's and that's usually the
best that's usually the channels i feel
that survive
is the ones that have variety i feel
like you've got to just keep
surprising your audience yeah
but i hate the comment that annoys me
the most uh i've all
hate comments i'm excited for this i
don't even know what to say because i
know everyone's gonna start commenting
it
right it's like the comment which i get
a few times a year
this guy's run out of ideas
once or twice a year we don't want to
punch someone we all know
i've been in japan
it's just like come on look at the stuff
i've tried to do this year like there's
so much weight
like i've always do i've always wanted
to ask people like what constitutes us
running out of ideas
i don't know like like what is it well
it's it's odd right because i feel like
a lot of youtube comments are like
do the same thing again yeah like
they're like yeah but then on the other
hand
there's he's running out of ideas
but what i don't understand is that
there are always people who every single
upload no matter what you do
they'll always be comments that say oh
it's run out of ideas i'm like you
wouldn't think that if i'd actually run
out of ideas i wouldn't be uploading at
all
i've i've had it every year for like
eight years now after a year of doing it
yeah i have rubber now
every year be like this channel's picked
like 2014's what this channel's reach
it's zenith it's not good it's going to
be [ __ ] now
and then it went on to get better like
you know so that's the comment
i know more about your channel than you
do
everyone does think they're an expert
yeah
and it's always you know it always sucks
as well because whenever
i've had at least with me i've had a few
times where i have genuinely been like
oh [ __ ] i don't know what to do
with that guys he's actually ran out of
ideas you know like where i get like an
artist block and i don't know
what to do right right and i think i'm
gonna ask my audience
right that's that's always the worst
thing and and i go on twitter being like
hey guys what what what content would
you like to see
and there's always that really one
popular vote that's like
very vocally spoken about you're like
well i guess people want to see it
99 of the time you make a video like
that it gets [ __ ] viewed
yeah as well and i'm like oh it's the
[ __ ] vocal to be fair i do i do ask
sometimes because like
ret there's sometimes there is like a
genius idea like one
i've never had more than one good idea
it's rarely the top voted one no it's
never
yeah it's never the top voted one and
most of the ideas you get are just
kind of like just the recycled ideas
that anyone can all the top comments are
just like react to reddit memes please
it's like
no i'm i'm good man i'm really good yeah
audience suggestions can be a slippery
slope yeah when is when when are the
audience going to get what they want
chris broad reacts to people reacting to
chris broad
people want us to do like a boat ride on
journey across japan right
on a boat and do quite a fun day that's
that's a good idea i was like
on a boat what are you gonna do on the
boat just
complain about it it's going to be
amazing this boat's here
we're going to like circumnavigate japan
on a boat
write that down write that down